[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина,
Юр'ївка]
Зараз тут проживає 16 людей.
Називається [село] Юр'ївка.
Магазина немає: розібрали, продали, розвалили.
Початкову школу закрили, зробили клуб.
Як приїжджали з Івано-Франківська буряки полоти,
[Іван Гура
Пасічник]
то жили в клубі ці «полівниці».
Потім його розвалили.
А річка то й взагалі висохла.
Із Гадяча повернулись сюди у 1988 році.
Поїхав я на зустріч однокласників.
Хата, стіни і дах, тоді уже були зроблені.
Спочатку походили по школі,
потім уже основна частина.
Сиділи за столом, і тут однокласниця питає:
«Ваня, ти не знаєш, що за дурень
у Юр'ївці будується?»
— Знаю.
— А хто такий?
Я.
Як починали займатись пасікою,
то купили два вулики і станки.
І вперед.
Уже важко впоратись, 140 їх.
Син допомагає.
Старшому дав свій кусок, більше 40 вуликів.
Він сам ними займається.
А меншого ніяк не вмовлю,
каже, що приїжджатиме допомагати.
Допомагати легше, ніж робити.
Оці п'ять вуликів з бджолами.
Літають вони на двір.
А ось це сітки для вентиляції.
Звідси йде запах.
Лягаєш і чуєш ту бджолину музику.
Сеанс відпочити — хвилин 40, до години.
Лягаєш на вулики і відчуття, ніби кудись зникаєш.
Цей шум.
Наші просять, щоб не замикав.
Вони приходять в 4 годині полежати, подихати.
Для органів дихання кращого й нема.
Я багато працював на землі,
того й знаю, що таке астма.
Після пасіки я й забув, що це.
Взимку... Ну це не муха, що у сплячку впадає.
Кілограмів 15 меду залишаємо,
5 чи 6 кілограмів на цукор.
Ось в цьому вулику, наприклад,
20 рамок —  літр.
На зиму залишається 8 чи 9 рамок.
У кожній має бути по 2 кілограми корму.
Бджола сідає знизу рамки, [ближче] до дна.
І потихенько підіймається угору, споживає корм.
Завдяки цьому виживає і гріється.
Улітку температура там 35 градусів.
А взимку достатньо 15-17.
Влітку більша температура для того,
щоб вижила мала бджола,
яйце, що мати відкладає.
Ми 25 кілограмів накачуємо з вулика.
Ну ще пилок збираємо кожного літа.
З оцієї пасіки було 500 кілограмів цих крупиночок.
З кожним роком...
Ви зараз бачите, що на полях твориться.
З таким прогресом, з ядами,
ми скоро меду взагалі не побачимо.
Цього року з акації взагалі не було.
Негода була.
А так буває потроху, вибірково.
Коли проходитимемо акації, то дам вам.
За 5 кілометрів була гречка.
І в цей момент цвіла липа.
То це був цього року перший такий мед.
А після цього залишається трави і соняшник.
На нашій території гречки
я вже давно не бачив.
Еспарцету чи інших медоносних —  теж.
Колгосп у буряки вдарився.
У буряки й в отрути.
Давненько планував насадити лип.
Почали рахувати, а їх небесна сотня.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерка
Наталка Панченко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
BLOOMS CORDA, Manu, Fudo Kazuki, Plly K, ZenBetty]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
— До побачення, дякуємо.
— До побачення!
Ви уявляєте, як це — прощатися з такою компанією і залишатись одному.
Немає з ким поговорити, нічого.